in February of 1990 during issue number
86 of the New Mutants Marvel will
introduce a character who will not only
become a mainstay in the Marvel Comics
universe who will also go on to become
one of the top favorites of Marvel comic
fans everywhere what's going on guys
this is Rob and today we're going to be
talking about cable
so cable is one of these examples of
what happens when people mess around
with time that cable is for all intents
and purposes a paradox he is the result
of his own actions and I'll explain what
that means here in a second but one of
the more intriguing aspects of cables
personality is that cable is guided by
one absolute desire over all others and
that desire is to kill apocalypse now
before we get too far into this we
really need to lay out some concepts and
some individuals with regards to the
relationship to cable because cable kind
of came about due to the actions of a
handful of people the first concept I
guess that we need to discuss is
something called the techno-organic
virus the techno-organic virus is
exactly what it sounds like unless
you're thinking that it sounds like a
virus that makes you dance to techno
music the techno-organic virus is a
virus that consumes organic tissue at
the molecular level and basically
converts it into metal there's a little
more to it than that but for the sake of
our discussion we'll go ahead and leave
it there now as far as the individuals
of course first and foremost is the
person we already discussed
that's apocalypse apocalypse is really
kind of the reason why cable is where he
is in life and kind of why cable has the
mindset that he does apocalypse is
really kind of the person that set it
all in motion after of course cable
himself now the next person is mr.
sinister and mr. sinister is someone
that has not been featured in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe which is a little
disappointing because he's a very
interesting character mr. sinister is a
relatively old individual that is to say
he was I guess exposed to technology in
the 19th century he's actually the
result of experimentation by apocalypse
but sinister had long since believed
that the genetic offspring of Jean Grey
and Cyclops would produce a virtually
unchallenged mutant and because sinister
is the result of the actions of
apocalypse he's really kind of bound to
apocalypse and so Sinister's goals for a
long time have been to rid himself of a
pot
lips his goal would I guess his drive to
do this was to manipulate Scott Summers
and Jean Grey into having a child with
which he could essentially take from
them and then raise that child in his
own image in order to push this child
away or I guess pushes out in a
direction to where it could effectively
destroy apocalypse or at the very least
render him virtually weak and and
powerless to do pretty much anything now
the next two people are of course people
that we've already mentioned Scott
Summers and Jean Grey but a popular
misconception is that cable is the
progeny of Scott Summers and Jean Grey
the reason why that's incorrect is
because cable is actually the progeny of
Scott Summers and nate'll and Pryor now
a lot of you guys don't know who
Madeleine Pryor is that Madeleine Pryor
has never been mentioned in any
incantation of Marvel outside of the
Marvel Comics there was a time during
the x-men storyline and I believe it was
the Secret Wars but I'm not going to
swear to that where Jean Grey was
basically piloting all the x-men back to
the planet Earth and a space shuttle and
it really kind of make things short the
Space Shuttle was crashing she reached
out telepathically to the Phoenix force
and the Phoenix force put Jean Grey in a
kind of stasis in the bottom of Jamaica
Bay to allow Jean Grey to heal from her
radiation sickness because of this and
because of the fact that Phoenix who had
now taken the form of Jean Grey hadn't
made herself known on a global level a
lot of people had assumed that Jean Grey
was dead including Cyclops and so
because of this mr. sinister cloned Jean
Grey and the clone was named Madeleine
prior now there were a couple of the
things that ended up happening but as a
result Madeleine Pryor came into contact
with Scott Summers Scott Summers
immediately bonded with her and believed
that she was Jean Grey and they of
course conceived cable now the next
person is Rachel summers and again
Rachel summers hasn't been mentioned in
any incantation of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
Rachel Summers was the time-displaced
child of Jean Grey and Scott Summers
from the Days of Future past they're a
mishmash of circumstances the days of
future present thing
like that and ultimately she ended up in
the 39th century eventually the time
comes when apocalypse realizes what mr.
sinister his goals are and he infects
cable with the techno-organic virus when
this happens Rachel summers travels to
the present and takes cable to her time
in the 39th century believing that he
can be cured of the techno-organic virus
the problem is that by the time they get
to the 39th century the virus has
expanded to such a degree that there can
be no cure for him now other things are
taken the clones created and strife
results of that but we're not going to
go into it to strife or anything like
that
um but nonetheless because of the fact
that cable is infected with a
techno-organic virus it really kind of
creates this interesting scenario within
himself Cable has virtually unlimited
telepathic and telekinetic abilities he
is an astronomically powerful character
but because of the fact the
techno-organic virus is trying to
destroy his body he uses his powers to
keep the techno-organic virus at bay to
keep it from consuming his body and so
that's what makes him kind of
interesting he can do all these amazing
things with his powers if it just
weren't for the techno-organic virus
infecting his body so when I say that
cable is a paradox here's what I mean
because of the fact that cable is in the
39th century and because of the fact
that in the 39th century apocalypse
rules the world he is part of a tribe
called the clan s canny and the clan of
scanning exists to try to overthrow and
destroy apocalypse now because of the
39th century of course technology is far
more advanced and one of the aspects of
technology of the time is time travel so
cable ends up going into the past on
several occasions one occasion of
traveling into the past is travelling
all the way to the distant past to the
very early days of apocalypses existence
and when I say very early I mean within
the first couple decades of apocalypse
being alive he attempts to kill
apocalypse and is unsuccessful but he
infects apocalypse with the
techno-organic virus because apocalypse
is infected with the techno-organic
virus apocalypse is now able to
communicate with celestial technology
and is able to grant himself these
extremely advanced powers because he's
able to grant himself these advanced
powers much later on down the line
thousands of years later he's able to
infect cable with the techno-organic
virus and that's why cable is kind of a
dog chasing its tail cable is really
kind of a man chasing his own shadow
here because he is a result of his own
actions he gave apocalypse of
techno-organic virus and was in turn
infected with the same techno-organic
virus that he infected apocalypse with
when it comes to cable on an individual
level what he lacks in power he makes up
for with technology of course being from
the 39th century as we've said his
technological advancements are far
greater than they are in the current
time stream so he has super advanced
weaponry he has Graymalkin he has a
great walk ins of this great huge ship
that he uses he has Holograms and all
kinds of different technological devices
but there have been a few instances
where despite the fact that he has this
overriding drive to destroy apocalypse
that he's deviated a few times when it
comes to the relationship between cable
and pot and apocalypse it can be best
compared I think to the relationship
between terminators and John Connor
and I know it sounds a little weird to
make that comparison but if you give me
a minute I think it'll all make sense
with the terminators every single
terminator no matter no matter what it's
programmed to do has a single program
which says if you see John Connor kill
him and if this program is initiated it
will override everything else so you
could have a terminator that's designed
for whatever reasons you just bang his
head against the wall and we were just
using it as an example and that's all it
does all day long is bang its head
against the wall but if John Connor
happens to walk by it'll immediately
stop and try to kill John Connor with
apocalypse in cable it's a lot of the
same way now of course cable isn't so
single-minded that his drive no matter
what it is it's to always kill
apocalypse but every act that he commits
every team that he joins every storyline
that
gets engaged in is always on the way to
trying to find a way to kill apocalypse
and it's for this reason that he's
always in a state of flux with
apocalypse it's for this reason that he
is always kind of in this mental battle
between the situation at hand where he
has to be an ally with apocalypse and
his drive to kill apocalypse that makes
him so intriguing in addition to the
fact that apocalypse is a very
intriguing character in and of himself
and so for the most part when you see in
when you see a crossover storyline where
Cable appears there's a very good chance
that apocalypse is going to show up and
everybody loves to see him so with that
being said I'm going to go ahead and
wring this video to an hand I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later peace